also man kann quasi sonne withers
teilnehmen einfach in crafting table mit
einem banner reinpacken dann bekommt man
dieses totenkopf teil und mit dem dodge
apple bekommt man das gleich mit zum
neuen logo also dass auf jeden fall
richtig richtig cool
hallo ich in meiner lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft fakes heute am dienstag
ein bisschen später war ich gerade sehr
sehr lang meinem steuerberater saß und
viele daran zu erklären hatte und
blablabla aber hey sie kommen heute mit
so wie letzte woche dass sie nicht am
freitag sondern am samstag gekommen sind
ich habe mir gedacht heute für die
dienstags folge kommt er natürlich
wieder ein geräusch und ich habe immer
so ein paar kommentare von euch zu
herzen genommen weil ich ja mit euch
zusammen diese serie gestaltung defekts
eigentlich von euch kommen habe ich
diesmal sehr sehr langen effects geguckt
dass ich wirklich sehr sehr cool effect
zur vorstellung nicht so 08 15 facts wie
beispielsweise josef liegt man schneller
da hat ein paar leute das kritisiert
deswegen leute die sonst immer nur
kritisieren sind oder ein scharfes auge
haben bitte diese vorher ganz genau
anschauen weil ich mir gibt mir diese
folge mal wieder sehr viel mühe nicht
was die bearbeitung angeht das mache ich
eben mal sondern bei der textauswahl und
ich würde sagen wir können endlich
anfangen mit dem ersten von louis und
zwar als bombe dafür erstmal genau wir
gehen erst mal den easy mode und spawn
hier sorgten monster als sie mir hier so
ein paar zombies nahm das glaube ich und
ich habe hier ein flat ins team und habe
ich den tollen command sammeltrieb ab 1
und so kriegen wir ein paar kripo jetzt
fragt ihr euch warum mache ich das ganze
und zwar wenn ich diesen kripo anziehen
und ein geladener creeper dann
explodiert und in dem explosions radius
irgendeinen monster mit sich zieht dann
lässt dieses monster teilweise einen
kopf fallen von diesem monster selbst
normalerweise sind dass ihr diese rolle
ob die noch manchmal vorkommen dass man
manchmal irgendwie den sonnenkopf kopf
beispielsweise bekommt allerdings ist es
damit viel häufiger der fall und ich
glaube sogar immer also bei mir ist
bisher immer geklappt und einfach das
feuerzeug weil du läuft jetzt nicht
unterscheidet das ist doch jetzt nicht
wahr
ich fahre hier alles voll mit zombies
oder läuft er in das ist wundervoll
wie machen wir das ganze mal kurz runter
entschuldigung so braucht nicht immer
noch ein paar zünde ich den mal eben an
so jetzt explodiert er nämlich und jetzt
sehen wir da ein paar ok hat es nicht
geschafft die zombie zu töten ich kriege
ja wohl die krise da möchte ich euch mal
was cooles zeigen und funktioniert wie
das nicht so erwartet jetzt ist aber mal
die zombies seiner umgebung sorgen als
hat nämlich die zombies getötet und wir
sehen hier schon das erste
hier haben wir einen zombie head mal
schauen ob wir noch mehr hier irgendwo
finden da oben ist nur weizen da sich
auch nur weil man auf jeden fall schon
mal ein zombie hält mehr sehe ich jetzt
auch gerade gar nicht ich sehe hier noch
ein paar blöcke ein paar blumen bisschen
dass die umwelt ein bisschen kaputt
gemacht okay aber wir können auf jeden
fall sagen jetzt hat er mir aus 13 wies
hat er mir auf jeden fall einen zombies
calbe schwer beschert ich gehe aber kurz
da oben hin macht das hier noch mal ein
paar zombies hier sind ja auch da hat
ein paar im umkreis so sportlich immer
noch ein lass den mal hoch gehen
schauen wir uns das hier noch mal an ob
hier auch ein zombie kopf ist da unten
liegt nämlich auch wie ein zombie kopf
und mehr und ich es kann auch sein dass
er immer nur egal wie viele zombies
einer luft sprengt dass er immer nur
einen zombie kopf ist wir machen es mal
hier nochmal wir zerstören japan die
komplette welt sondern fliegt das auf
meiner luft und wir haben da wir haben
auf jeden fall im inventar ich glaub ich
hab mir selber nicht gesehen aber werden
auf jeden fall jene drei stehen das
heißt haben drei zonen köpfe also wenn
ihr im normalen modus irgendwie auch ein
zombie kopf kriegen wollte so hatte das
ganze begründet die einzige möglichkeit
dadurch quasi in dem ihr eingeladenen
creep annehmen und dann irgendwie die
zombie star im umkreis die dropmann
immer im kopf wie oft man allerdings
geladen
überfälle das ist sehr sehr selten und
ich glaube die kommen ja nur wenn die
irgendwie vom blitz getroffen werden und
das passiert halt sehr sehr selten
genaueres ist schreibt seine kommentare
aber das war auf jeden fall weg nummer
eins und so kann man sehr gut sein kopf
kriegen und mock up allgemein
ich habe schon drei minuten für den
ersten tag gebraucht dann kann dich
louis wir machen direkt schnell weiter
im programm nächste feld wurde mir
zugesendet von nicolas und zwar meint
nicholas es gibt ja dieses tolle
leuchtfeuer das kann man hier aktivieren
indem man da einfach entweder
eisen blöcke goldberg oder diamant
blöcke darunter setzt und dann kann man
hier drauf zugreifen kann man sanyo in
diesem umkreis möchte ich den speed oder
heißt oder resistenz campus oder ein
paar verschiedene sachen kann man
auswählen im gegenzug für ich weiß gar
nicht was noch mal ich hab es offenbar
dafür diese sachen über nach einlegen
kann gerne auf und allerdings hatte der
nikolaus gesagt joab der 1.8 ist es
allerdings möglich dass man diesen
strahl färben kann also alle die
irgendwie sich eine coole villa gebaut
haben und dann unten gegen die st daran
haben wir denken ja die ganze villa ist
grün aber dass teile hatten weißen
strahl machen sie den strahlt einfach
grün oder wenn man will kann man das
ganze auch roth machen dann sieht das
ganze roth aus oder also es kommt darauf
an was hier oben steht also ich kann mir
zum beispiel auch so ein blaues
hinsetzen kann ich damals ein schwarzes
hinsetzen
okay das ist ein bisschen blöd das ist
alles durchläuft da mag die teils mal
kaputt und jetzt sehen wir ich muss es
einfach so mehr oder weniger damit
verbinden dass es irgendwie über die
blöcke damit verbunden ist das heißt als
ein schwarzes einstellen und was ihr
beispielsweise auch grad schon gesehen
hat man kann die farben fertig kann es
beispielsweise mal ein gelbes entpacken
und ich könnte jetzt mal ein
ich muss machen ein schwarzes hinstellen
und ihr seht ihr dass dieser strahl so
ein bisschen gelb schwarzes ein bisschen
eklige farbe setzen wir mal bloß darauf
dann ist das ganze jetzt jeden moment
verändert sich das ganze nämlich da ist
das ganze so blau geld wenn ich jetzt
allerdings diesen hier wieder weg machen
würde oder beispielsweise hier einfach
mal einen blauen hinsetzen würde würd
mir den hals das teil komplett blau ist
also so kann man seinen leucht blabla
auf jeden fall färben sein sein sein
leuchtfeuer
das ist richtig dass man kann da
bestimmte mischung der farben machen
hier müssen wir jetzt irgendwie ich bin
noch nie so großer kunstexperte gewesen
genau gelb und rot ergibt orange jetzt
haben wir so eine art orangene mischung
und die teile werden immer mal so ein
bisschen gemischt ich finde roth immer
noch am allermeisten ich finde roth
sieht richtig bedrohlich gefährlich aus
richtig intensives rot gefällt mir
richtig gut
schön dass man so was jetzt machen kann
wenn ich zum beispiel nie draufgekommen
dass es jetzt geht und dann kann dich
nicolas so freunde wisst bescheid wies
am dienstag läuft und zwar dienstags
immer die folge dran wo ich ein
geheimnisvolles geräusch daran nehme
freuen wenn ihr jetzt denkt io dies ist
mit dem iran ist ein geräusch regt mich
total auf dann schaltet am besten direkt
ab und bewertet dementsprechend das
video nicht positiv sondern geht einfach
zur folge dann am freitag also wartet in
drei tagen ab weil am freitag kommt nie
das geheimnisvolle geräusch also wenn
euch allerdings ist eine tolle gelöscht
doch interessiert dann bleibt jetzt dran
weil ich zeige euch jetzt das letzte
geheimnisvolle geräusche erraten wurde
von mathias bury der da meint du hast
eine kugelschreiber auf und zugelegt und
es ist richtig matthias odermatt es
heißt du glaub ich genau mattes das ist
nämlich genau richtig ich habe einen
kugelschreiber auf den züge kläger war
das letzte woche jedenfalls war das
letzte woche das geheimnisvolle
geräusche das geheimnisvolle geräusche
für heute was ihr jetzt die kommentare
spam könnten eventuell mit etwas mit der
nächsten folge bildet ist dieses
geräusch wenn es erraten habt dann
schreibst und in den kommentaren
wirklich für die nächste sache wurde mir
zugesendet vom villiger buddy vanessa
dank an dich vanessa und zwar habe ich
hier poppitz ich weiß nicht einfach die
papis heißen aber auf jeden fall so rote
rosen dann blaue euch den und flower
potts und zwar stelle ich jetzt einfach
mal so ein paar flotten und wir können
ja ganz
mal wenn wir so richtig machen blumen
setzen wenn wir allerdings liegen können
wir da keine blumen reinsetzen das geht
nicht ich drücke ihr rechtsklick ich
weiß nicht wie ich das zeigen dass ich
rechtzeitig drücke ich nehme mir so ich
drücke ich drücke passiert nix kann man
nicht jetzt toll jetzt ist jetzt ganze
kabel wiederum weg es geht auf jeden
fall nicht man muss nämlich bei der
ganzen sache stehen und dann kann man
diese blumen da ist einsetzen
warum das ganze so ist und was es euch
bringt kann ich nicht beantworten es
bringt euch nichts es ist nur kollegen
die zu wissen das ist ein fakt leute
theoretisch ist alles ein fake
theoretisch könnte ich als fan demo mit
linksklick macht man blogger putz ist
auch ein fact also von daher
es ist auf jeden fall eine sache die man
auf jeden fall sich mal ins gedächtnis
rufen sollte warum das ganze nicht
funktioniert ich weiß nicht ob es nun
backt sondern sogar eigentlich kann man
mit shift wenn man eben was rechts
klickt ist es doch eigentlich so dass
man mit schiff kann ich nur rose setzen
ich habe auch so eine rose setzen aber
irgendwie dem flower pott nicht also das
ist irgendeine relativ komische sache
ich verstehe nicht warum
und nur wenn ich dann quasi wieder
hochgeht das ganze ich weiß einfach
nicht warum und ich werde darauf auch
nie gekommen aber es ist ein fakt
freunde und dankelmann dich liebe
vanessa nicolas hat mir einen sehr
coolen fag zugesendet irgendwie es in
dieser folge jene person die mir was zu
entdecken was mit nico drin aber naja
wir setzen hier nämlich erstmal eine
oder ich mach das mal grad wo es ein
bisschen dunkler ist vorgesehen die
ballnacht keine ahnung warum aber ihnen
wird alles ja heute was mit leuchten zu
tun
ich stelle meine fackeln oder sind
natürlich sehr schön aus und man kann
jetzt keinen arm aus dem entpacken wenn
man das ganze beleuchten will seinen arm
aus der mit einem niemandsland muss man
dafür daneben stellen man kann
allerdings auf die fackel drauf nicht
irgendwie dran sondern auf die fackel
drauf dann ist er quasi darüber uns
fällt in die fackel rein und dann ist
hier quasi fackel genau zwischen den
beinen und verbrennen diesem typen die
kröten da so ein bisschen jedenfalls
haben wir das jetzt quasi drin das ist
ein beleuchteter armor stand und wenn
mir die fackel kaputt machen wollen
müssen wir quasi erst mal am arm aus den
vorbei also kann man quasi ein armes
land beleuchten fackeln zu packen und
wir können ganz einfach auch ich
praktisch
rüstungen hier dran dann sehen wir ja es
leuchtet ein fachmann sieht die fackel
halt nicht man sieht nicht mal die sau
raus also man sieht ja egal wie schwer
man sich auch anstrengen man sieht eine
fackel außerdem oben braucht so ein
bisschen der schädel immer mal so ein
bisschen wie sieht man dass es da hat
man es ein bisschen sehen da vorne kommt
noch ein bisschen rauch heraus
aber ich finde es auf jeden fall eine
richtig coole sache um diese arme aus
denn zu beleuchten und damit die noch
ein bisschen gefährlich aussehen cool
wäre wenn man ortes licht von fackeln
ändern könnte wie bei diesem teil davon
aber das hatte der rat schon gelernt und
auf jeden fall dank nicht nikolaus
defekt und ich werde auf jeden fall so
machen wenn ich nahm aus der dinge mache
oder in mamer bau oder in wenn man
braucht egal wie man wollte mit dem
letzten weg der nächste effekt wurde mir
zugesendet ebenfalls von einem nico also
das ist genau der gleiche nico damit
übrigens auch diese effekte zugesendet
hat er sehr sehr cool ist nico du bist
echt was das angeht jedenfalls und ein
kumpel stoffes von zwei leute die mini e
mail geschickt haben ihr kennt ja den
ganz normalen golden apple die man sich
mit den goldnuggets macht damit kann man
nichts besonderes machen wenn ich das
mit einem banner da irgendwie rein läge
also den kann man direkt mal links mal
kein mensch den habe ich wahrscheinlich
jetzt ja da habe ich nie wieder
allerdings kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
diesen golden apple diesen lodge apple
aus minecraft skeptisch die man mit gold
blöcken macht also dafür braucht man
acht gold blöcke und einen apfel in der
mitte und wenn ich den damit rein läge
dann bekomme ich bei einem web banner
und dem lot apple bekomme ich einen
banner wo ein mojang logo drauf deswegen
motto young logo blabla sehr sehr cool
geht auch bei anderen farben also wenn
ich dann irgendwie diesem diesen
goldenen apple und mehr allerdings
gepackt hatte wird es ganz auf
funktionieren und was ich euch auch noch
zeigen wollte ich nehme jetzt mal einen
ruhiger kopf habe jetzt den ritter kopf
lege den hier beispielsweise mal rein
und niemals beispielsweise mal ein
yellow banner oder ich nehme es
beispielsweise in grün
dann habe ich hier einen ball ex-coach
arsch und das ist ein
ja also das ist unseren totenkopf ging
also man kann quasi sonders teilnehmen
einfach in crafting table mit einem
banner reinpacken dann bekommt man
dieses totenkopf teil und mit mitchell
bekommt man das gleich mit zwei jacken
logo ist auf jeden fall richtig richtig
cool
danke an die kolosser für fürs einsenden
oder nico ich weiß gar nicht womit sich
ein anderer die ganzen namen
da kann man auf jeden fall richtig coole
sachen mitmachen es waren glaube ich
diesmal alles wieder 1.8 facts mit der
1.8 so neu dazu gekommen sind wie
beispielsweise mit dem arm aus denn mit
den bonnern mit dem leuchtfeuer ging
glaube ich auch noch nicht vorher bin
ich auf jeden fall nicht so sicher das
war's mit der heutigen folge der
minecraft facts die nächste folge kommt
am freitag ich mache das immer noch so
lange pro woche zwei mal wie ich gehe
noch folgen haben wie ich genug genug zu
meinem posteingang habe und das sind
mittlerweile so viele und ich hoffe die
serie gefällt ich habe ein bisschen mehr
mühe gegeben mit den facts und paar
coole sachen tragen aber wenns euch
dementsprechend gefallen da würde ich
mich sehr sehr wohl bei einer bewertung
freuen weil die sehne mich am meisten
zeit kostet zu planen zu bearbeiten
aufzunehmen et cetera pp es ist quasi
die einzige serie auf einem kanal wo ich
sicher sein kann die o2 meine woche
kommt eine folge ich hoffe ich konnte
das geheimnisvolle geräusche raten tut
mir leid dass ich ein bisschen schnell
redet aber die folge soll ja irgendwann
auch heute online kommen und dann wegen
meinem internet und blablabla erstmal
tief durchatmen
was gibt's sonst noch zu sagen crafting
ideen werden in letzter zeit sehr viel
nachgefragt wann die nächste folge kommt
das ist sehr schwer zu machen wenn ihr
allerdings mal das könnte ich auch
machen wenn die kräfte ideen habt für
mich dann schreibt mir die auch mal an
die mail com kraft der ti mail.com
genauso wie eure effekt ideen wenn
effekt hat auch ein kräftiger dot co dot
kräfte gmail.com einfach in den betreff
minecraft 1.8 effekt und eventuell seit
in der nächsten folge dabei und
eventuell auch in der nächsten kräftiger
dies folge ich bin total ko ich die
fällig wer das ganze zu verarbeiten
hoflader direkt pennen gehn
ich bin so fertig weil ich bekannt doch
tausendmal sagen meine lieben viele
jogger dies ich habe übrigens meine
mutter guckt mich an